alors qu'elle a mis si je vous dis
chauffard et accident de voiture est-ce
que vous pensez à votre film avec le
Palmashow ou au fait qu'en ce moment
pour Palmade c'est chaud
[Applaudissements]
vous vous dites vous avez commencé avec
lui Pierre Palmade
on n'a jamais été des amis mais on a
commencé ensemble à la classe je l'ai
emmené faire des premières parties en
Belgique et dans le monde c'est
dramatique ce qui lui arrive mais foutez
lui la paix
ce qu'il a fait aussi est dramatique ce
qu'il a fait mais foutez lui là il sait
c'est c'est il y a rien rien à dire
juste laisser la justice faire ces
choses et n'en rajoutez pas
heureusement que Christophe Dechavanne
est là sinon c'était un scandale
monumental c'est-à-dire que foutez-lui
la paix il n'a pas un mot pour les
membres de la famille qui ont été
percutés dont tu as été encore à
l'hôpital qui souffre de compassion
il va pas faire comme tout le monde
écouter tout d'abord je voudrais avoir
une pensée politique
qui m'a choqué c'est y a rien à dire si
il y a à dire la drogue c'est dangereux
ça tue des gens il y a à dire que si on
a reçu pendant des années des
personnalités comme Pierre Palmade qui
disait dans tout le monde que clairement
c'était des junky et tout le monde
trouvait ça marrant et tout le monde
trouvait ça normal donc s'il y a à dire
et tout ça pour dire que je pense parce
que lui ce qui veut dénoncer c'est le
voyeurisme on n'est pas que dans le
voyeurisme dans cette affaire on est
dans le décryptage d'une certaine partie
de la société qui est malsaine et qui
est dangereuse et c'est pour ça que
c'est important d'en parler c'est pas
qu'il y a rien à dire c'est qu'il y a
plus rien à dire qu'on a tout dit en
fait que maintenant il prend juste la
parole pour dire il y a plus rien à dire
il y a un humoriste qui fait une vanne
certes c'est un peu trash c'est un peu
noir mais c'est drôle et lui à ce
moment-là lui coupe la parole il dit oh
là là arrête foutez-lui la paix ça va
c'est dramatique genre c'est dramatique
pour lui c'est lui à ce moment-là qui
remet une pièce dans la machine vous
êtes d'accord ou pas
j'ai pas compris la question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle a vu que la prof était sur ses
côtes et il a fait
non mais même si un sang il est un peu
maladroit mais c'est un vieil ami donc
je ne pense pas que lui-même pense à mal
en disant ça il dit que comme le dit
tout à l'heure Valérie tout a été dit
tout le monde a dit ce qu'il fallait
dire tout le monde a dit qu'il fallait
mettre d'abord la famille et les
victimes en avant et tout ça et que il y
a un moment on en a un peu on a
l'impression que ça y est on va rabâcher
une fois de plus et que ça suffit moi je
pense que c'est ça qu'il a voulu dire
donc je ne pense pas à mal en disant ce
qu'il a dit mais c'est pour ça qu'on a
le droit de laisser un humoriste faire
une blague c'est de la crème hydratante
pourquoi j'ai besoin de m'hydrater la
poche
merci les chéris
dans cette séquence parce que moi pour
l'instant je trouve que les blagues sur
Palmade il faut il faut les laisser
tranquilles il y a encore des gens qui
souffrent donc ça vraiment ça me dérange
premièrement et les deux phrases sont
malades à droite foutez-lui la paix et
ce qui lui arrive et dramatique
heureusement que Christophe Dechavanne
est derrière mais ça ça reflète ce qu'on
pense on le connaît pierre Malba depuis
30 ans on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
passer plutôt à lui et non mais c'est
qui Palmade
mais c'est très maladroit et moi tout ma
journée la blague rapide un peu sortie
de route c'est pas le mal la drogue
c'est pas le même le camsec c'est pas le
mat ouais c'est devenu un peu le symbole
de toutes les dérives de la société et
c'est toutes ces toutes les blagues sont
systématiques sur lustre
on avait pas eu son avis sur Pierre
Palmade et ben écoutez moi je trouve que
on loupé quelque chose je suis désolé je
suis d'accord avec vous non mais je peux
parler distinctement j'ai pas les
distances de moi je trouve que je trouve
que ce qu'il a fait au contraire est
courageux il est un des rares dans ce
métier pas tourner le doigt pas pierre
Palma en disant effectivement ce qu'il a
fait dramatique il a porté un peu ses
corones la différence de beaucoup de de
ce métier qui connaissent très bien et
qui n'ont rien dit il a dit voilà je
trouve que c'est plutôt bien et c'est
plus note de sa part excusez-moi dans ce
cas précis et qui c'est qui qui vous a
soutenu tout le week-end c'est qui c'est
moi qui les rapports après
[Rires]
un petit bisou non pas de bisous
donc c'était ce que je voulais dire sur
voilà sur cette sortie qui est plutôt
plutôt courageux je trouve voilà
d'accord quel est après c'est peut-être
pas fait spécialement une façon de
porter ces trucs comme tu dis parce
qu'il peut aussi avoir eu des amis
plus être son ami ou enfin tu vois c'est
pas parce qu'on a été ami qu'on est amis
éternellement si tu penses qu'une
personne elle est allée je sais pas mon
avis personnellement mais c'est pas
parce que lui a fait ça que les autres
n'ont pas de trucs tu vois ce que je
veux dire tu es pas obligé à vie d'être
amis
mais c'est positionné ce qui est
courageux c'est tout ce que je dis le
niveau est trop moi j'arrête
[Applaudissements]
je voulais juste te dire que c'est pas
parce que les autres le soutiennent pas
qu'ils ont pas de couilles ça veut juste
dire peut-être qu'ils sont pas d'accord
avec tout ce qui se passe ils sont déçus
je pense que voilà je pense que c'était
pas la peine de rajouter